hello and welcome to this video playing
snuba here with white and he's playing
the Petrov ok so in the pan off I go for
this line which okay he goes back that's
it that's possible it sound very solid
way to play with black yeah so what is
he up to here as he tried to take them i
will get the pawn back so I'm not so
concerned so we definitely is playing
very quickly that that one we already
see so I'm I've lost a bishop pair of it
I've got a really nice development going
here and he has some weaknesses in the
center so what's going on here um take
no dd5 needs to a Ben Oni type of
position which is at least something
that I have some knowledge knowledge off
however if i take taking looks logical
ready and then that Queen to be five
going to be six it's probably pretty
pretty good position yeah I think this
is correct let's think about this though
do have some other square even I guess
not but this is good huh it looks okay
how is he covering the pawn going to be
six and if i take it and Bishop 2d6 that
should be a decent ending mmm I won't
live its best though
at the end you might play I'll be five
like takes takes bishop d6 takes takes
b5 is possible yeah but it still looks
looks correct maybe maybe I should go a4
a.m. and stop b5 that make some sense
actually I still threaten Bishop t6 and
if it goes Luke the eighth i have Bishop
d7 yeah yeah probably think that looks
promising ya know invest time being
already in a pretty bad position I think
so Bishop d6c going back on what is the
thing this is on the agenda anyway I
could have gone Bishop c7 as well but
that it looks really that looks fine I
mean if it goes Bishop the eighth and I
cannot complain about it I mean that's
that's nice not quite clear what I play
then to be honest wit it must be better
for wine
and that takes rook takes it's difficult
this b6 prawn is a constant problem i'm
happy with a for it was a good move I
think to fix his weaknesses okay um how
to do this here be 3 92 94 something or
be 395 on b3 you might have c4 maybe but
it so it looks good anyway I think I'm
bishop there ok that's an interesting
choice attacking see true so it takes my
my weakness they're taking us it's not
helping ok so i'll just do this cover c2
maybe Bishop c7 was the clock the clock
was even better couple of moves ago it's
very much possible so what about this
ending here 95 then he's no no not
really I wonder if 95 was really best I
can also play a 3 here I think I go f3
[ __ ] f2 ok the most concerning thing
is the time situation position is quite
nice I mean it's not winning from you
anything but it's a comfortable ending
he's still stuck with this b6 pawn Ruby
six ism get the threat yeah one day I've
actually do this but I have to speed up
I'm not quite sure where where I put the
night after this do I want to trade mm I
don't know i don't really i really don't
know what it is a good ending but it's
i'm not sure if it is enough to to win a
game the bishop has some kind of kind of
annoying so we get to Luke ending
c3 King c4 I would like to get this in
it would be nice he wants to go King f4
ok
check for g5 when it's got f6 though if
six might be okay for him oh yeah my
being again the time assists the water
would concerns me most here cap yeah i
blundered this pawn that is not good
it's not good check
check to give check
should be at all I should be a draw
check aim draw okay it's probably okay
this result I mean with the time
management um um yeah it was tough to do
something in the ending I mean um black
is very much worse around here it's just
difficult to do something with those
time disadvantage I don't know I don't
really know where this dissipated maybe
it's it's difficult here to avoid the
trade of the bishop which is yeah bishop
a taxi tool as you feel and see the
engine known gives me some comfortable
advantage but maybe this was wrong I
really don't know maybe I need need two
nights to attack his weaknesses there
maybe that's since that's the case the
engine wants to cough play like this and
then lie to be five what tonight be five
about ninety six maybe and she wants to
go 98 that doesn't look so active so
this weight went six books e6 it's also
it's interesting also you to consider to
take this is not a really great poor
information on the Queen
side I was wondering if this is maybe an
idea what year what you have to keep in
mind is said if you if you think about
this kind of position like king of aid
I'm 993 yes it doesn't have you don't he
does not have to take bring this yeah if
he takes it this is excellent yeah
really excellent I can surprise the road
king before i was thinking king see
forward would be very good also like
like this t3 something before is this
3523 and yeah now the engine is climbing
I get that I get the passer here this is
a well known structure that should be
very good here but I have thought he
doesn't have to take him and just place
this and I'm not sure if I'm making any
progress yeah I cannot move the night
that well because it was always hanging
so it was nice but I'm sure if I can do
much about it guarantee i've got the the
active rook so it must be better for me
but ok is true kings before the engine
immediately says this is right ok this
is a kind of yeah I'm quicker I'm cooker
I was all black automatically stopping
black skin but this is yeah I'm a much
quicker right it's something like this
I'm winning I'm winning a couple of tan
Pai with King and rook and now I already
have a passer so this was kind of a joke
is gonna play now ok I didn't see it in
the game I was playing this to just two
yeah keep-keep what I have
okay Luke h eight is better I can't hook
a chain win the corner yeah i was
thinking had this is also good but he
has f6 which i didn't really appreciate
fully king c4 is also good yeah and here
here i'm i'm losing any any advantage
yeah i'm not sure here be five wins i
had to play quickly at that point I was
thinking I might be able to trade that
as well but I'm not quick enough for you
can why is that losing because if I
taking you for and yeah yeah yeah so I
actually has brought the ending at one
point I think here here i should be able
to draw right here after this i'm pretty
sure i can but wait he could have gone
down here I'll take it c4 yeah I'm so
slow here probably yeah I'm probably too
slow on c3 king of 318 be 30 meter slow
be 5i stopping me from from advancing
okay so I'm with do this c2g had this f5
okay okay okay hmm Wow and then I'm in
trouble okay really really really wrong
so I still was it was lost year with he
goes kingi form you know Nana was bad
ending to bed and gameplay I should
never really get into trouble from this
position but yeah I'm not naturally good
in those technical position and I need a
bit of time
I don't have the time sometimes really
play a pretty bad news ok guys thanks
for watching